- It's also Mother's Day this Sunday
so we wanna celebrate mama's.
(audience cheering)
Mary, do your kids celebrate with you?
Do y'all do anything special?
- They do, but I'm a grandmother now
so part of what I'm
celebrating is my daughter Lily
who's just an amazing mother herself
and yeah, it's like the whole,
any excuse for our whole
gang to just pile in.
Dogs, kids, babies, everybody.
It's wonderful.
- That is wonderful.
Especially as a grandma now.
- Yeah, I love being a grandmother.
It's so boring to say
but it is the greatest thing in the world.
- I do too (audience laughing)
- [Kelly] I know it's
special, it's different.
- We text each other
grandmother photos all the time.
- It's so, it must be so odd too.
I have a six and eight
year old, but I can't
so obviously I can't imagine.
But like to have your kids be mothers
you know what I'm saying?
Like, that's, that's interesting.
That dynamic like being
like, wait, you're mom too.
That's just weird.
I can't look at my eight year old and go,
I hope you do well. (laughing)
Like, I hope I did well enough.
What about y'all?
What do you do Diane?
- Leave me out. (laughing)
- Leave me out.
You're like, I don't wanna
celebrate Mother's day.
- I'm just going to sit here.
I'm enjoying it.(laughing)
- Okay, well I gave you wine.
I like this and
- I'm glad I have this.
- She's mildy inebriated.
- [Kelly] I like this.
- I'm sorry I can't share
with you everyone (laughing)
but I'm gonna drink up
right now. (laughing)
(audience cheering)
- [Kelly] We're gonna celebrate for you,
for Mother's day.